if you are concerned about marrying a
Nazi because you in fact are not a Nazi
listen that's kind of a tough hurdle to
hop over okay this says hi Crowder I
love the show also please don't use we
didn't include your name please don't
use my name very hard to use your name
my girlfriend does not do anything
specifically racist alright I have not
read this before going on air just so
you know so I have no idea what kind of
a left turn this letter can take so I
cannot be held accountable for the words
that I am about to speak there you go
confirmed in front it is alright
specifically racist when she she does
not do anything specific by the way the
reason I'm not illiterate I'm trying to
learn does not do anything specific like
fix applause they're specifically racist
really yeah I know that means that
racist but when she handed me her phone
to text her mom that we would be late
for dinner her background was a Nazi
flag and I found an audio file on her
phone labeled Heil the fur I think you
made sure there's an ER after that he
really liked mink scared of walking
outside at night because she thinks a
gang of black in all caps will rape and
kill her when she goes out at me she
requires mrs. Mel Gibson and I love this
woman with all my heart and want to
marry her in the future how can I help
her
not specifically racist except for the
Nazi flag and hail the Fuhrer yeah so I
think I might be in a little bit of
denial here yeah I have a very serious
question are you having sex because that
will cover up a lot of these types of
issues if sex is great and you're like
this is fantastic she's the one and
these like gigantic red and oh I thought
we were asking like to identify body
black she has a swastika too like the
Michael Jackson oh the kid was like well
Michael has a mole on his left butt
cheek and it
I would say that I mean that seems
pretty obvious right it's a fan of the
show so somebody who should be
well-adjusted somewhat to society and
not be a racist Nazi flag toting hail to
the Fuhrer guy and he's seeing that and
he's saying specifically racist although
she does seem to be making racist
comments pretty much all the time on the
regular based on the rest of his email
yeah I think he's living in a bit of
denial and I'm wondering why is there
something else that's making you covers
gonna be like a day or two or the guys
like oh - well yeah never gonna find
another girl look look if she really is
this right and you you need to ask these
hard questions today today sometimes I
wonder if it's real this is a real email
and I know that some of them are but we
get so many this actually does seem
pretty well we go it goes through a
process a little bit like a water
filtration process but sometimes through
you know when there's a little black
there's a little bit of Salmonella in
the water she could just consider World
War two collector of memorabilia no I
know people like that what you need to
do is get Christopher Plummer from that
film where he's like he's like a 90 year
old Jew who ends up telling all the
people remember and I think it was an
officer he was in some kind of an
internment camp yeah and you just do
anyone else ever see that in Argentina
right I don't know no I don't think I
don't know Christopher Plummer the point
is I prefer Plummer and it's like a
metal detector for not find someone who
knows whether someone or not is a real
Nazi Oh Oh ask her to go to a Jewish
synagogue with you and go to church is a
horrible of guys no that's not bad
person in the news no I don't want to
see him on the news I didn't mean like
that person with a Nazi flag on their
phone I know Jim welcome to a synagogue
you'll know whether she's gonna be like
no I cannot do it
you know you'll know right there and I'm
not saying that she would actually go
and do something I'm saying she'd look
at it or you're just giving her the
greatest opportunity in neo-nazi history
your gift wrapping it to them it's not
true it seems like you think she's gonna
be like no no I can't Jim okay this
person hates Jews they're gonna find any
opportunity to go to a rap concert yeah
yeah but then then you might both get
mugged
that was my point
the answer to the question will be your
end okay here's the deal this goes back
what we've talked about with Democrats
and Republicans and people getting
married to her
conservative Christian not Christian I
love this with all my heart and want to
marry her in the future for stuff why
serious people don't realize this they
let they let colloquialisms turn into
what they what you believe is a truth
right I love this one with all of my
heart no you don't what do you what do
you mean the part of your heart that
sent this email
nobody loves everybody with all their
heart it's not true he loved me just the
way I am he'll never love you just the
way you are for all of your flaws he'll
love you in spite of those flaws this
idea that oh if he loves you he won't
try to change a thing about you that's
not true I love this person with all of
my heart that's not true
oh I couldn't live without you that's
not true none of those things are true I
understand they look nice in a Hallmark
card but to allow them to then define
your parameters in the way that you did
and the way you decipher your these
decisions in your relationship it is
very very dangerous you love this woman
with all of your heart even though she
has a Nazi flag and a helmet of fur as
you put it on her phone something tells
me there's something in your heart going
like oh maybe that's this section we
love him is most of our hearts but not
obvious and nosebleeds it's a little bit
of doubts there that's what's happening
and people just say this all the time oh
I love them with all my heart well
what's another one that we hear all the
time we hear uh-oh I knew I knew it was
love at first sight for crying that's
the stupidest thing I've ever heard of
love at first sight now there can be
lust at first sight there can be
interaction at first sight but love at
first sight there is absolutely any guy
who tells you that is lying and more
importantly if a guy tells you that and
he's lying you have to be asking
yourself what kind of what kind of
questions are you asking of him to put
him in that situation where he feels
like he has to say that or you could
just be a lying dick like that's guys
saying I love this won't all my heart if
you close the Valentine's Day the point
is don't let a Hallmark slogan determine
how you how you navigate relationship
you don't love this woman with all your
heart you probably shouldn't which means
you probably shouldn't marry this person
if you are concerned about marrying a
Nazi because you in fact are not a Nazi
listen that's kind of a tough hurdle to
hop over
do some research here it seems like
you're avoiding some of these big
shining lights right in your face what
Nazis no just just just leave let me
make this one as simple as possible okay
no you don't uh she's perfect boy she's
no she's not
this policy let me ask you this okay you
found this on her phone now assuming
maybe she's trolling let's eliminate
these possibilities right or this could
be you know this could be someone just
making a joke that being said let's
assume that it's not and I also it seems
to me that you're concerned enough about
it not being a joke that it warranted
this email right life advice that letter
of credit com will do another one of
these here in a couple of weeks really
simple okay one question are you a Nazi
pretty easy
I'm your guru see you next time hey
there YouTube viewer if you like this
video watch one of my other videos
oh it's playing in one of those boxes
I'd say subscribe or hit the
notification build but I don't really
know what that means in today's day and
age on YouTube but if you join it louder
with Crider comm slash mug club you
won't at least see clips you'll get to
watch the full daily one-hour show every
single day and support our content
making sure that we can still get clips
up here on YouTube for the freeloaders
who can't afford it and/or are just
cheap pricks